- Now because Jennifer you took a bit of Friends when you left at the end -I took all five of them
- But some of the set you got - Oh wait, yes
I got uh, I took a the neon, the neon coffee mug from the coffeehouse - Cause you sent us a picture of it
So where was that in Central Perk - Oh that's in my office
So yes, that's from the coffee house right when you would walk in the door to the right - Central Perk? - Yes, Central Perk
- That's so exciting - They did ask me though
I didn't cause that would be a hell of a thing to try to take off a set - But Reese, Legally Blonde 2
You walked away with more than most
- Oh
Well, I got all my wardrobe - Yeah, how many pairs, how many pairs of Jimmy Choos? - Like 77
- Seriously! - I had it written in my contract
(audience clapping)
- Good right
- Do you still have, did you wear all 77 of them - I have all of them, well I did in the show yeah
And I've, well no I've never touched them and then on the 15th anniversary
I took them all out of storage and tried them all on, some of them fit some of them didn't
Yeah
Yeah, it was really cool and I showed them all to my daughter and it was really cool
- Cause Judy, you mentioned your first husband who designed Mary Poppins - Yes - Did you, did you end up getting loads of those props?
- No, the only thing I did take home and I think he may have done it for me
Was the the, the pretty little pink and white button-up shoes, another pair of shoes
From Mary Poppins' outing with with Burt, those there they are
- Oh oh ok, and do you still, do you still have them?
- Yeah, they're door stops now, they were filled with, filled with sand and look very pretty